no what do you got something you gotta
unload yes
what is it camera four that's my camera
yes it is
hey listen y'all know i think that most
reporters are cowards they want to be
friends with these players
y'all just proved my point again for the
first month of the season y'all blame
everything on russell westbrook for the
lakers been putting all them old ass
geezers together and y'all blame
westbrook
now i hear y'all gonna fire frank vogel
listen
russ is learning frank volga is a
terrific coach putting all them old ass
geezers together just trying to blame
other people it ain't right and it ain't
cool listen anthony davis you got to
play better i said on this first night
if the lakers were going to be any good
it was all going to be on you has
nothing to do with russell had nothing
to do with lebron and the rest of them
old ass geezers they put together out
there but now y'all don't cross the line
because i really like frank vogel and
listen it ain't his fault but listen
it's in my opinion i blame anthony davis
davis you know i like you as a person
but you ain't you ain't doing what
you're supposed to do you're 27 years
old you're supposed to be in your prime
you're supposed to be one of the five
best players in the world up there with
giannis kevin devon and those guys and
you ain't holding up your end of the
bargain so now i hear y'all going fire
because that's total bs man now i feel
better
but wouldn't it be and that's why we're
here to make you for what about couldn't
have been you would have like
it didn't happen yet it shouldn't even
be discussed who's discussing it
he's catching
some hits
yeah but in reality i'm with you but
what's reality that's reality we don't
know if it's realistic
no no no you know how i know you're
going to get fired when they start
asking you if you're going to get fired
there it is but kenny me and him always
have this you know discussion it
shouldn't be on the coach anyway we as
players got to step up ada like chuck
said he ain't holding up to his bargain
if you're shooting
that bad from the three-point line
that's telling me one thing get your ass
in the post where you belong
get your ass in the post stop shooting i
would say
52 from the 52 from the floor 19 percent
from three for anthony but the other
thing
the other thing that the lakers you know
their their their fans and their and the
people that follow the lakers have
delusions of grandeur they're not
who they are first of all lebron james
hasn't been there
for to take more than half of the season
don't do that again no i'm just saying
i'm not saying when giannis did not have
lopez and jew holiday he
buck struggled they haven't he's not
been there so so you better break it on
the third year guy going to make a
difference
because he handles the ball too much
should he handle the ball but what about
a.d after the days being one of the five
best players in the world 100 okay has
he played like it no he's not but he
hasn't had the team around him i'm not
sure he could still be kicking ass
without